liberal leaders don't seem to be big
fans of liberal policies take radical
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg he's
practically famous for not Prosecuting
violent criminals and for charging
Marine Daniel penny in the death of the
mentally ill homeless man it was
threatening Subway Riders now it looks
like Bragg's afraid of the monster he
created
I know the statistics at Transit crime
is down but when one of my family
members gets on the train I too get a
knot in my stomach
brag's not alone 61 percent of the New
Yorkers say they worry they could become
a victim residents in other liberal
areas feel the same but Democratic mayor
Eric Adams thinks it's all just media
hype
these are the day picking up the uh the
news the morning papers they sit down
and they see some of the most horrific
events that may happen throughout the
previous day it plays on your psyche
we're clear on that but my mission is to
move people from what they felt to what
they're feeling and no one can take away
the fact this city is humming cities
humming Harold
so I think I learned a long long time
ago in politics that
um you can't tell someone how they feel
uh and you can't tell someone if they
they don't feel safe you can't tell them
they're safe and if they don't feel
financially better off you can't tell
them if an answer better you can you can
meet them where they are and try to
demonstrate how the numbers are
improving and ask them what more can you
be doing but I think that the most
interesting and telling piece in our in
our opening there was Alvin Brack saying
that he too is concerned when a family
member he gets I think he said a knot in
his stomach when they're when a family
family member is on the subway uh I
think the mayor uh is doing uh a good
job but he he's not doing a good job on
this issue here the way he's talking
about if I were him if I were going to
have that comment that he made it he's a
he's a friend I'd have been on the
subway making that comment shouldn't
Alvin Bragg judging ride the subway like
some of these other politicians from
Bragg and mayor Adams should both be on
that Subway tell the mayor to stop with
the nice stuff and spend more time
during the day and if 81 percent of New
Yorkers feel that crime is a very
serious issue and more than 60 percent
of word they're going to be a victim
then it's not about perception or how
they're feeling or how the Press is
telling them how to feel it's because
they know what to feel they're afraid
they're going to become victims and you
know when Adam Bragg says he admits he
has a what is it a knot in his stomach I
mean well maybe he should think about uh
Daniel Penny when Daniel Penny felt that
knot and his Husband yeah in his stomach
but I think he's going to go the same
way as Lori Lightfoot oh I think that
mayor Adams is doing the same thing she
she reprimanded the Press she said
they're making it all up he's doing the
same things he's saying the Press is
going out of their way and the New
Yorkers are too dumb they have to
believe what they're reading in the
newspaper he's going to go the same way
she is because New Yorkers need this
city to be safe for businesses to be
successful and for people to feel that
they want to live here New Yorkers have
been waking up in the morning and
reading the newspaper for a pretty long
time Dana what's changed well that's the
thing I love that observation judge
about Lori Lightfoot because I hadn't
thought about it that way she did start
to do that remember it was like it was
everybody else's fault but hers it was
like guys like you can actually see with
your own eyes on Monday morning what
would we report what happened in Chicago
over the weekend and here um that we're
here we're living amongst it and this is
the most traveled to city in America
second most traveled to in the world
Paris is first I don't know why
um but I look at some of the people that
are traveling here I'm like I'm sorry I
want to apologize to the tourists and
say it is so dirty it's so filthy I'm so
sorry there is trash everywhere I'm so
sorry that you have to dodge to make
sure you're not getting attacked
including on the front page of the New
York Post this morning they have a
picture of a guy at 10 A.M in a very
crowded Times Square with a huge knife
walking around at time at 10 A.M and
there's all these tourists there and
they just they work hard they bring
their families here they're paying more
for the hotel rooms because guess what
more than half the hotel rooms are
filled with migrants so that means
there's a law of supply and demand that
means the cost for the tourist goes up
and I just want to apologize to them on
behalf of
people who live here how cute is it that
Dana wants to apologize to tourists that
our city isn't clean it's disgusting
all right I think tourists are part of
the problem though
yeah I do I do and I'll tell you why
because they always give money to the
Panhandle that always I lecture them I
go do you want me to go to where you
live and find somebody living in front
of your place and give them money to
stay there because that's what you're
doing right now in my neighborhood big
jerk that I punch him in the face then I
run and I hide you know you know what
kills me is that it's I I respect what
the mayor is trying to do but that's not
the truth the crime isn't in our head
because the it's he's saying it has to
do with media coverage but we know
better than anybody that the media
basically dead walked the crime wave for
two years right because they didn't want
to link it to the post George Floyd
riots we saw this coming we saw that the
the uh what he called the Ferguson
effect take hold but the media spent a
long time tell basically gaslighting a
phrase I hate but gaslighting us saying
oh it's not that bad no it's because
nobody's processing the crimes it's not
like the crime is going down and Brad
should be lucky it was just a knot in
his stomach right could have been a
knife you know he basically just
admitted that his policies his policies
put his family in danger that's some
kind of Dad yeah like Daddy why am I
scared on the subway it's because I put
ideology over decency and morality it's
on me that you might get hurt I mean he
just admitted he's a crappy dad and he
won't do anything about the knot yeah
yeah he can still do so he'd rather put
his family at risk right sure all right
and I think we learned one thing
tourists do not give any money to the
homeless yes I want to Brian kill Mead I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the anyway that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now